We just landed after a 10 hour flight
and the first thing my husband requests is a hot dog.
So instead of running to the store I just decided to make it myself.
I started by cutting up some pork and placing that in the freezer
while I got started on my hot dog buns.
Combine some yeast, sugar,
and milk. Let that bloom
while I started on mixing all of my dry ingredients together.
I added some melted butter before combining my wet and dry
and adding an egg. I gave that a good mix and once it came together
I covered it for five minutes before turning it out and kneading it.
I then placed my dough into a bowl and let that rise for 45 minutes.
In the meantime, I got started on making some mustard.
My husband doesn't have ketchup on his hot dog,
so I just made some mustard for him.
I took it off the stove,
I set that aside to cool and diced up some onion as a topping.
He doesn't care for relish so this makes it a lot easier.
For 45 minutes
I punched down my dough and form it into little hot dog shaped buns
before brushing them with some egg wash
and baking them for about 15 minutes.
While those were cooling, I got started on my sausage.
His favourite sausages are German ones,
so I opted for that instead of the classic hot dog sausage.
Once my meat Was ground up.
I got started on all my spices.
Pour those into my meat
before letting that combine for about three to four minutes.
In the meantime,
I washed my casing and let it soak for about 30 minutes.
For stuffing that with my meat and twisting it into little links.
I worked on this in batches.
Poach them for about three to four minutes,
fried them off, and then it was time to assemble.
I put my bun and sausage down,
topped it with my condiments, and he loved it.